ya hemos visto algo de
pérez
en varios vídeos ellos han sido nuestros
útiles solventes apro ticos en varias de
nuestras reacciones pero pensé que ya
era tiempo de que le diéramos un vídeo o
dos a los cetes y como todas las cosas
que hemos hecho en química orgánica una
buena forma de familiarizarnos con las
moléculas y cómo se ven es de hecho
nombrando las así que vamos a nombrar un
par
las primeras ya las hemos visto entonces
digamos que tenemos esta molécula de
aquí esta molécula de aquí y lo que voy
a hacer es que les voy a enseñar dos
formas de nombrarla el nombre común que
probablemente es el más importante
especialmente con éter es porque como
pueden imaginarse ese es el nombre más
común es el más conocido y luego también
les mostraré cómo nombrarlo usando la
nomenclatura iupac así que déjenme
escribirlo nombre
qué es la unión internacional de química
pura y aplicada y ellos inventaron los
protocolos oficiales para la
nomenclatura de todas las moléculas
orgánicas
esta es la convención que utilizamos
antes para nombrar a los alcanos y los
al que nos pero en el caso de los
heteros su nombre común es más común
entonces el nombre común para esta
molécula de aquí si vemos los dos grupos
de carbono de aquí veamos
tenemos este de aquí ese es un grupo de
tilo ese es un grupo
lo tenemos 12 carbonos y luego vemos el
otro grupo de carbonos de este otro lado
ese también es un grupo de tilo tenemos
12 carbonos por lo que lo llamamos
déjenme escribir esto ese también es un
grupo
y
dilo entonces el nombre común el nombre
común para esta es dietil éter
til
y el letter nos dice esta parte nos dice
que tienes un oxígeno entre tus dos
grupos de tilo este es el nombre común
este es el nombre común
y ahora para el nombre oficial de la
unión internacional de química pura y
aplicada tenemos que hacer algo similar
a lo que hemos hecho antes con otras
moléculas buscamos la cadena más larga y
lo volveré a dibujar voy a dibujar en el
lado izquierdo los nombres comunes y en
el lado derecho los nombres iupac vamos
a volver a dibujar
el dietil éter buscamos la cadena más
larga en este caso hay dos cadenas más
largas está esta que tiene dos carbonos
y también esta que tiene 12 carbonos
puedes escoger cualquiera voy a escoger
esta como la cadena principal esta de
aquí tiene 2 carbonos ningún doble
enlace es un eta no es 1
y luego decimos bien tengo un tengo un
grupo al coxis y cuando es así ponemos
el término ok si al final porque tiene
este oxígeno de aquí pero la parte al
que tiene dos carbonos 1 2 así que
llamamos a esto
lo llamamos stock sí
tops y entonces una forma de llamarlos
tenemos este grupo detox y unido al
carbono 1 y vamos a empezar a enumerar
en este lado del etano porque es allí
donde está el grupo unido al carbono 1
por lo que lo llamamos 1 stocks y etano
entonces este es uno
toc sí
eta no casi nunca lo verás con este
nombre aun cuando este es el nombre
oficial es más probable que lo
encuentres como dietil éter al menos a
mí me suena más este nombre y solo te
preguntas cuáles son los dos grupos y le
agregas la palabra entera al final ya
que sabes que están separados por un
oxígeno hagamos un par de moléculas más
digamos que tengo esta molécula de aquí
tengo esta molécula de aquí la forma
común es viendo a los dos grupos a los
lados del oxígeno este de aquí y voy a
cambiar de color este grupo de la
izquierda de aquí tenemos 123 carbonos
es un grupo propio pero están unidos al
carbono de en medio convirtiéndose en un
grupo y su propio grupo
sol
pro piris
y del lado derecho tenemos sólo un
carbono este de aquí lo voy a poner en
amarillo
este es un grupo metilo este es un grupo
me
tilo
en la forma común de nombrarlo solo
nombras a ambos grupos y después
escribes éter al final y se colocan en
orden alfabético la iba antes de la m
por lo que el nombre común
sol
pero piel
y su propio el metil isopropílico
me tiro
éter isopropílico metil
tierra
ahora si hiciéramos el nombre iupac
buscamos la cadena más larga de carbonos
voy a volver a dibujar la molécula voy a
volver a dibujar la misma molécula y
cuál es la cadena más larga aquí pues
tenemos 123 carbonos en esta y sólo
tenemos un carbono aquí por lo que esta
es la cadena más larga tiene 3 carbonos
y no tiene dobles enlaces entonces el
met prop propio o mejor dicho propano
esta es nuestra cadena más larga
entonces escribimos
pero para no
aquí
porque estamos usando la nomenclatura
iupac y luego vemos este grupo med occ
sí de aquí y le llama un grupo med occ
sí porque tengo la o que nos da el ok sí
y sólo tengo un grupo metilo aquí por lo
que este se llama
med occ sí
me toques y recuerda que metes el
prefijo para cuando sólo hay un carbono
y le agregamos ok sí porque está ese
oxígeno ahí y está unido a los dos
carbonos de la cadena de propano sin
importar en qué dirección comencemos a
nombrar o numerar
todos
este es dos métodos y propano
me
toc sí
dos métodos y propano hagamos otro
ejemplo solo uno más
y creo que le van a ir encontrando el
sentido de la nomenclatura de al menos
de tres simples pongamos una pongamos
son pongamos un anillo aquí
este unido a un oxígeno y luego tenemos
otra cadena de carbono aquí otra cadena
de carbono ahí voy a copiar y pegar esta
molécula para no tener que volver a
dibujar después copiar y pegar
excelente entonces hagamos el nombre
como un primero que es casi siempre más
divertido bien en este lado tenemos 1 2
3 4 5 6 carbonos en un ciclo este del
lado izquierdo
es un grupo ciclo exile o grupo
klopp
si lo
exilio
del lado derecho tenemos 1 2 3
es un grupo
grupo pro
y cuando nombramos al éter sólo ponemos
estos dos grupos en orden alfabético y
después añadimos éter al final entonces
queda como ciclo xxi la cba antes que la
p ciclo
sí no
ciclo
sí
profil
lo pondré en color amarillo ciclo exile
pero
eterno ciclo exile pro pil
ahora sigamos la nomenclatura iupac
buscamos la cadena de carbono más larga
en este caso va a ser el ciclo hexano
tenemos 12
6 carbonos y tenemos 12
es carbonos aquí por lo que esta es
nuestra cadena
escribimos ciclohexano
cloud
hexano
no tiene dobles enlaces por lo que es un
ex ano
entonces este es un ciclo hexano si sólo
tuviéramos si sólo tuviéramos estos tres
carbonos sería un propio pero este no
tiene sólo tres carbonos son tres
carbonos y luego viene un oxígeno por lo
que lo llamamos probox y este es un
grupo pro box i
pero poc sí y no tenemos que enumerar
esta cadena porque puede estar unido a
cualquiera de estos carbonos y
esencialmente sería la misma molécula
entonces podemos llamarlo probox y ciclo
hexano pero
sí
si lo hexano pero de nuevo el nombre
común es el que probablemente
encontraras y ya que hemos nombrado
algunos c3 pensemos un poco en sus
propiedades
lo que ya hemos visto y lo que hemos
usado varias veces especialmente en
reacciones de tipo sn 2 y así cuando no
queríamos que hubiera protones por allí
usábamos 10.000 éter y en general los
tres son buenos solventes tienden a ser
poco reactivos entonces
buenos
sol
benítez
especialmente cuando estás buscando un
solvente apro tico recuerda que a proto
significa que no vas a tener hidrógenos
que puedan perder un electrón ante un
átomo electro negativo como sería un
oxígeno y luego que ese protón este
flotando y que pueda reaccionar con
otras moléculas éste no tiene hidrógenos
directamente unidos a un oxígeno en
cualquiera de estos casos por lo que son
solventes a prácticos y es porque no
tiene ningún hidrógeno directamente
unido a un oxígeno tampoco hay enlaces
con moléculas de hidrógeno así que
hagamos un pequeño repaso sabemos que en
el agua tenemos esta situación voy a
dibujar unas moléculas de agua aquí
en el agua tenemos la situación en la
que el oxígeno abraza a los electrones
por lo que tiene una carga
parcial negativa los electrones del
hidrógeno les son abrazados o quitados o
pasa menos tiempo con ellos por lo que
tiene una carga parcial positiva
entonces este oxígeno va a tener una
carga parcial negativa y entonces los
hidrógenos con la carga parcial positiva
son atraídos a los oxígenos con carga
parcial negativa generando este puente
de hidrógeno
y este puente de hidrógeno es lo que
hace al agua es lo que une a las
moléculas por lo que se necesita ponerle
más energía para poder fundir o para
poder llevar el agua a ebullición para
que las moléculas se separen las unas de
las otras
ocurre lo mismo con los alcoholes los
alcoholes sólo tienen un hidrógeno para
cada oxígeno pero de todos modos forman
puentes de hidrógeno en el caso en el
caso de los 3
no forman puentes de hidrógeno
representaré cada una de las cadenas de
carbono con una ere y otra
r le pondremos se reprima aquí para
mostrar que puede ser una cadena de
carbono diferente a esta de aquí
y la r significa radical no se debe
confundir con radicales libres son
conceptos totalmente distintos está r
sólo representa una cadena de carbono
unida a este oxígeno pero aquí los
electrones los electrones del hidrógeno
no son abrazados por oxígenos con carga
parcial positiva ni carga parcial
negativa por lo que no va a haber
fuentes de hidrógeno
y es por eso que los c 3 tienen puntos
de fusión y ebullición mucho más bajos
se debe poner menos calor en el sistema
para que estas moléculas se separen
unas de otras dado que no se atraen
tanto mutuamente